I got a story for you got a story here
it's from just the news
about a professor who was placed on
leave
for giving out chocolate bars
this professor is David Richardson
David Richardson is a 33-year veteran of
the state center Community College
District he has 27 years as a full-time
tenure track history instructor
uh he's he's one teacher of the year
Madeira Chamber of Commerce president's
medal for outstanding faculty at Reedley
College for the Madeira campus he has
never once in his entire career had a
bad professional evaluation he's never
had a complaint of any kind
until 2021 right around all of this
crazy pronoun transgender Madness and
now this man who by all accounts all
evidence around is an outstanding
Professor who everybody likes because he
handed out a politically incorrect
chocolate bar I don't even want to go
that far a chocolate bar
that made a little bit of a joke about
how men and women are different because
of that this guy has been placed on
leave we need to protect ourselves not
just in our careers we need to protect
our bodies that's why you got to check
out bulletproof everyone right now go to
bulletproof everyone.com use promo code
Knowles
bulletproof everyone is a premier
American Body Armor manufacturer and
supplier designed and built for everyday
wear their unique armor systems offer 25
more coverage than standard armor while
maintaining flexibility and all-day
wearability bulletproof everyone's ultra
light armor system is so light it's so
thin you might just forget you're
wearing it at all your safety and
discretion is their top concern unless
someone puts their hands on you no one
will have any clue that you are
protected with bulletproof everyone you
are not a walking billboard there are no
visible logos no flashy designs they're
comfortable TaylorMade clothing system
goes above and beyond adding additional
security by keeping you Incognito and
under the radar work or Play Bulletproof
everyone has got the perfect armor
system to fit your everyday lifestyle
and everyday budget especially as our
political order gets a little bit crazy
great time to protect yourself right now
they're giving our listeners a free 3A
backpack with the purchase of any 3
clothing with code Knowles at checkout
kwles go to
bulletproofeveryone.com that is
bulletproof everyone.com promo code
Knowles
I am very pleased to be joined Now by
Professor David Richardson
put on leave for the Hideous crime of
passing out a fun chocolate bar in his
class and making a little joke about the
difference between men and women
Professor thank you for coming on the
show
thank you for having me Michael so
what on Earth possessed the
administrators to put you on leave
uh I I can't even speculate on that
I I don't have a clue
I just know that the suspension came
after
I um I was actually at an open house
event
for the college a week ago last Saturday
and uh we we had tables showcasing our
various programs
and uh I brought some of my history
memorabilia some stuff from the Civil
War World War II
and uh I I always bring snacks
I always bring chips popcorn drinks
things stand out to people who come
uh at my own expense by the way never
asked for any money for this and uh I
had some leftover
Jeremy's chocolates
that I I didn't know what I was going to
do with them I like chocolate but I
bought an entire case
a man of excellent taste yes I wasn't
gonna eat an entire case
so I I ate some but I brought the
remainder to the open house and I I
didn't say anything about them I just
had them on the table with all of the
other snacks and they actually ended up
being the most popular item
on the table
um
you know every most everyone seemed to
get a real kick out of it
and so
um you know we had one member of Staff
who
had not even noticed um when that person
first came by
and I guess words started to circulate
about what the the rappers actually said
and I even had some people asking for
for pairs
they wanted uh he him and she her
naturally and um
then all of a sudden shows up at my
table
demands to know what what they mean
I I directed her to Jeremy
I said you'll have to contact them
they they wrote the rapper
and took pictures of the chocolate bars
um
that was that pretty much so
um you so you you've been teaching for a
long time it's not like this is your
first couple of years on the job here
you've teached for a long time you've
got a long track record
student seem to love you've gotten all
sorts of awards
this one
little gift to people I won't even say
it's just a joke you were just giving
people a chocolate bar right can you can
you imagine now being put on leave for
giving someone a chocolate bar and it
involves a little bit of a joke about
this very novel very silly modern
political fad called transgenderism all
of that
gets you put on leave
on top of the fact by the way that as I
read here in your bio
you are not only not anti-lgbt or
whatever they're going to call you you
are a self-identified member of the LGB
community
yes
I I've been yes I'm in a long-term
relationship 23 years
um I I don't like to lead with that
because I would rather people focus
on my
my skills my abilities my you know what
I do
and I've always said last year
um our schools decided to fly the pride
flag for the first time
and I even wrote a statement to the
Board of Trustees at the time I said
don't celebrate me for what I am
celebrate me for what I've done
and
um didn't make a bit of difference I
think right they flew the flags anyway
but um
that's that's my philosophy
it's it's such an injustice and I think
I mean it's it's very admirable for you
to say look I'm not I'm not defined by
my sexual desires okay I'm about my
career how about my work how about how
about my thoughts how about all of this
but it just goes to show you the extreme
lengths that this movement will go to
cancel anybody who in any way it's not
like you're leading a pogrom against the
transgender Community or whatever
they're going to accuse you of
you made a little joke about a popular
chocolate bar and gave people a little
bit of candy and with that they can wipe
it out so uh David before I let you go
where does everything stand now I know
this this really all began your problems
with the the
college began a couple of years ago I
think regarding the same sort of an
issue same sort of thing I was accused
of
um quote unquote
mockingly
misgendering a colleague
and by misgendering of course you mean
properly gender
yes I used to correct pronouns that
evidently in a mocking manner
and was given a letter of reprimand and
forced to undergo training retraining of
course education re-education that's
that's what they used to call it now
there's a new politically correct
euphemism for it they call it diversity
training or so but it's like it's it's
the same old thing uh David I I really
hope that you Prevail here in your fight
I know that the headwinds that you're up
against are very very strong it's a
lesson to everybody out there if you
think that this mob is not going to come
for you if you think well look I'm kind
of protected I'm I'm teaching at this
smaller school I'm all I ever do I make
a little joke about chocolate bar I can
no it's it's a totalizing totalitarian
ideology if you in any way diverge from
it this totalitarian mob will come for
you I think the solution is we've got to
get Jeremy in addition to the razors and
the chocolates just start Jeremy's
University Professor Richardson can have
a tenured spot there we will be praying
for you in the meantime though keep up
the fight really thank you so much David
for for coming on
uh and for all the rest of you
very important for this story you can go
check out Jeremy's chocolates because
Jeremy believes in every free American
should have the right to hand out
chocolate that is why right now
you can get the delicious Jeremy's he
him and she her chocolate bars in a
snack size so pre-order Jeremy's
chocolate right now conveniently
available for Halloween go to Jeremy's
chocolate.com and pre-order today boy
what a clip that was huh if you want to
get more of those if you want long
interviews with Michael and if you want
the yes or no game if you want face off
if you want sizzling daily commentary
you gotta subscribe click that bell ring
that thing on the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time